test in testing
welcome everyone welcome everyone to
this cabinet meeting on the 28th of july
2022 um fire alarm procedures and if the
fire alarm is activated vacate the
offices via the stairs please not use
the lifts assemble in all the square on
the green and officers will assist you
and advise when it is deemed safe to
return to the chamber
next i'd advise everyone to please
switch off or turn on silent your mobile
phones and do not make or receive calls
whilst this meeting is in progress
uh please note this meeting has been
live streamed for members of the public
the meeting will also be recorded and
will be subsequently broadcast on the
internet uh does anyone intend to film
the meeting
no there's loads of paying hands that
definitely want to film the meeting but
no
um
members please note that the word into
recommendation recommendation 2 in the
report for gender item 4 ramsgate future
11 and up fund projects third-party
grants has been changed to reflect new
job titles it's been changed to
the
the grant agreement is signed under deed
by the interim head of legal monitoring
officer and not director of law and
democracy and acting deputy chief exec
and section 151 officer instead of the
director of finance and is witnessed by
a member of the council
the following members have asked to
speak under council procedure rule 20.1
i've got councillor everett for item
number four do i have any other
counselors
brilliant thank you council auburn if i
do end up forgetting about you just
start waving madly like you normally do
i know you won't i know you won't um
brilliant thank you very much um
apologies are there any apologies for
absence
the leader of the council supposedly
have a center apologies this meeting um
decorations of interest do we does
anyone have any interest to declare in
the items of business on the agenda this
evening
no brilliant
um
general item free to approve the summary
of recommendations um
and decisions of the cabinet meeting
held on the 16th of june 2022
a copy is attached to the agenda pack i
propose that we approve the minutes do i
have a seconder
councillor bob bayford do members agree
brilliant thank you very much agenda
item 4
is the rams gate future leveling up fund
project third party grants
which is um
to introduce me um and then i'll come to
council over to speak
um
so members
and counselors good evening um part of
the ramsgate learning up fund program
includes the establishment of a physical
and digital presence in deprived
neighborhoods and to support outreach
and training in linton this will provide
a commercial training kitchen facility
supporting initial skills development
and community enterprising food
members have been asked to approve the
recommendations report to provide a
grant of up to five hundred thousand
pounds to newington community
association for the delivery of this
project the grant will be used to extend
the building to allow the creation of a
kitchen training facility and make
enhancements to the building to create a
space where local residents can enter to
discuss barriers to employment and
consider new training and employment
opportunities
this is great news as we are now
starting to see the next steps of these
projects
um
being delivered the recommendations are
one to approve the use of grants which
exceed 250 000 pounds third parties to
deliver the agreed development uh
department of leveling up housing and
communities funded project
up to 500 pounds 500 sorry 500 000
pounds to newington community
association to deliver the access to
opportunities project in newington
community center and recommendation
recommendation number two is the grant
grant agreement is signed under deed by
the director of law and democracy and
the director of finance and section 151
officer and is witnessed by a member of
the council
to speak uh under 20.1 i have councilor
everett
thank you councillor um yeah i thought
i'd tell you about my lunch yesterday um
unusual thing to bring to a council
meeting but i had lunch yesterday at the
newington community centre conveniently
enough and that lunch was prepared by um
people who
come through east kent college who were
overseen by mike spankman who's the chef
who trains people in use of the kitchen
at newington
and there were about um two or three
dozen guests and it was a very good
lunch and obviously those people are
benefiting from hands-on experience
um and pretty typical of the sort of
thing that goes on at the newington
community centre and and relevant to
this obviously because what's being
proposed here is is a massive expansion
of a project which to some extent is
already in place and i think that's
that's fantastic news for uh newington
it's it's a it's a good
it's a good initiative because apart
from anything else uh it's a quick win
for the leveling up bid
um
when we were we started to put some some
flesh on the bones of the the leveling
up
for ramsgate i was particularly keen
that there was something for newington
not just because i happen to be a
newington councillor but also because i
think it's important that the people of
ramsky ramsgate see that this money is
for the benefit of the whole community
and we know that
in terms of isolation and in terms of
social exclusion newington is probably
the ward in ramsgate which is mostly on
the periphery and where people feel most
left out what's going on in the town
centre um it's obviously the case that
most of the leveling up money is going
to be spent in the portland harbor area
which i think is right economically that
doesn't mean it doesn't benefit the
whole town obviously it does but i think
the physical presence of something
happening in newington being delivered
in newington building on excellent work
that's already taking place in newington
and no doubt producing more good food
like my lunch yesterday um it's just all
good news so um i want to welcome this
and i'm delighted to see it thank you
thank you council revere um i agree with
everything you said
rather surprisingly or unsurprisingly um
thank you very much
um
therefore um
i i move the motion uh do i have a
seconder uh counselor cup uh do members
agree
agreed thank you very much
moving on to agenda item five the rounds
get leveling up fund heritage lottery
fund application
to introduce myself um and then i'll
come to uh councillor auburn for his uh
much longer awaited questions
i'm just gonna find
my section apologies
there we are
part of the ramsgate level and up fund
program includes investment in grade two
listed the greater listed clock house
refurbishing it as a cultural heritage
exhibition space and public cafe
the clock house will provide an
important publicly accessible focal
point for visitors and residents at the
heart of the royal harbour with a new
seafront cafe and a space for history
and heritage to be exhibited
officers have been working with the
round skate society and historic england
to develop a plan for the building and
for engagement with the heritage lottery
national lottery heritage fund a
proposal has been put together for a
funding application to the national
lottery
cabinet are asked to approve the
submission of a development phase
application into national lottery
heritage fund which forms part of the
match funding for the leveling up
fund project
therefore the recommendations are the
recommendation number one is to approve
the submission of an application for a
development phase grant of 322 740
pounds to the national lottery heritage
fund
and recommend recommendation number two
is that the director of regeneration is
authorized to agree the final submission
documents based on approval from
the section 151 officer therefore i
present this to cabinet um
to speak under section 20.1 i have
cancer auburn
thank you chair
um
whilst not wishing to make this a love
fest um i i
welcome this as well
um you know and anything that we can get
in ramsgate to
uh certainly look after our uh heritage
is is more than welcome and and i
support the recommendations
um
just a couple of questions um
within within the report
it it states relating to
the construction costs
uh that there will obviously be uh with
the current situation
uh construction costs are rising on a
regular basis because of materials
etc
have you got um a rough idea of what
those costs may be in percentage terms
just so uh
might be able to get that i'm looking at
louise if she may be able to answer that
for you
that's one
oh you want are you one all okay yeah
yeah okay um okay um
could you advise us
how much of the leveling up fund
has been allocated to the clock house
or is there no funding allocated to the
clock house only now
so that's that's the third one and
lastly but probably frivolously um
i did find it that what we're applying
for 322 000
plus
um and a match funding of 35 000 um and
it just seems an odd phrase to have that
you got thirty three hundred and twenty
two thousand and max
my view of match funding was like for
like but uh
i'm being pedantic here but uh
35 000 doesn't match up to 322 000. i
just wanted an explanation and i said
it's slightly frivolous but i i know
what you mean but
uh it just doesn't read read right sorry
thank you
thank you councillor album i don't think
anyone has ever said that you're
frivolous and i certainly haven't not in
a public meeting um but thank you
councilwoman
um no quite that as well castle bayford
but that won't be recorded in the
minutes um
i
agree with a lot of what you've said to
cancer auburn and this is an incredibly
important part of the leveling up fund
and i know that i've been communicating
with other councils as well from
ramsgate that
also have a keen interest in the
artifacts that are held within the clock
house and there at the maritime museum
and everything so you know it's a keen
interest that i've taken in
ensuring that we get this right and that
we crack on with this as soon as
possible um so that we can we can get it
sorted really um
you'll be surprised to know that i don't
have many of the answers to your
questions so i am going to
turn to louise i'm sure can elaborate on
on all of them so louise askew
thank you um so it's got 1.48 million
allocated to the clock house um
we the
the
report is about the development phase so
national lottery heritage fund is in two
phases so you put a development
grant application in that gives you a
period of time to develop up the project
using that funding um and our
expectation is that we will be
submitting a
um
bigger bid for con
for capital and revenue costs in the
region of 2 million
but obviously we need to do that piece
of work first
um
i'm not going to necessarily give you a
percentage for the construction costs
we've
we are phasing it so phase one is
leveling up and that's about making the
building good and secure and dealing
with some of the challenges the building
has and doing some of the works within
that building and then the lottery bid
is about the extension
and building capacity for that
building we have some very initial plans
um
and the ramsgate society did a piece of
work
four or four years ago five years ago
using some
and they had some costed up plans we've
worked from those but as you said the
the marketplace is changing what i don't
want to do is pre-determine what of that
will be construction um but what will be
in the lottery bid because the national
lottery is not about
buildings per se it's about access to
them so it will be broader than
construction works to the building it
will be about how people in ransgate
east kent and visitors can engage with
the history and heritage of ramsgate
thank you very much thank you louise and
i think i'd also as well add casserole
before we move on that i've been invited
to meet with
members of the ramsgate society so i'll
be taking them up on that offer as well
uh specifically to talk about leveling
up and and wider things like that um
councillor bayford you look like you
wanted to come in yeah thank you chair
um well i think it's very disappointing
the state that the clockhouse is in
um a bit of history i believe in about
2011 uh lease was granted to the current
lease holders um that lease
again i believe um had a lot of
obligations on the leaseholder in return
for rent free periods and it seems to me
in the
shoe in 11 years that virtually nothing
has been done so that's two things
really like an assurance that the
current leaseholders will gain in no way
from this that you know we're not going
to sort of you know do a local authority
thing but give them compensation for
doing nothing and whatever so that's
number one and number two
um that if they're they've got
obligations under the lease that they
haven't fulfilled they're enforceable
that we actually enforce order to seek
compensation from them because i think
it's disgraceful the way they're
treating the building personally
thank you councillor baker yeah i mean i
couldn't agree more i think that's
really important um
you know i can i can go to louise if you
can can you clarify that louise or do
you want me to waffle on i mean i think
it's more that i didn't want to put on
the swallowing i think that it's more um
but i have done that apologies um i
think it's more the point yeah it's fine
i will in a minute but i think it's more
important councillor baker that actually
we you're right uh they have certain
obligations and i think it's important
that they fulfill them and at the same
time we don't
compensate them for for handing over a
lease to a building that they've done
nothing with and as they've been of no
benefit to the town but i'll refer to
louise because she may have something to
add
yeah thanks so our legal team are in
contact with the
legal team of the current leaseholders
so that's kind of in process um
i don't think there's any compensation
being discussed in terms of ending of
that lease um i haven't got the
specifics necessarily about that but we
can we can cover that
sorry just briefly i mean one of the
concerns is that i believe it's 25-year
lease
that was was granted to them so you know
again just wonder whether that
potentially sort of gives it some value
that they might be trying to get out of
us and i just think we've got to make
sure we don't yeah well i mean cancer
paper that's very good point to raise i
mean that's something that we'll look
into and we'll ensure that actually um
not only do they relinquish the lease
but they don't benefit financially from
having to surrender that early i think
that's quite important so yeah but we'll
certainly take that away um
therefore i move these recommendations
do i have a secondar
counselor david saunders um
sorry do members agree
agreed brilliant thank you very much
moving on to agenda item six tenant and
leaseholder services
kpi
quarter four housing performance report
to introduce councillor jill bayford
thank you chair
this report covers our progress on
tenant and leaseholder health and safety
compliance and provides an update on the
overall performance of the tenant and
leaseholder service
during quarter four tdc came off
regulatory notice which was placed on
the council in 2019
this reflects the considerable
improvements that have been made for
landlord compliance
in december 2022 the team put in place
an action plan that would ensure there
is an acceptable level by march 2022
they were successful in achieving what
they set out to do
this included increasing domestic
electrical compliance figures from 74 to
90
and reducing our fire risk assessment
actions from 488 to 219.
the team's operational performance
continues to show improvements although
there are still some areas that require
attention to achieve the set targets
they avoid turnaround time has improved
due to recent measures put in place but
there is still some way to go to achieve
set targets and the team continues to
work with mirs and on internal processes
to achieve this
the final arrears figures for 2021-22
are the lowest since transition and
reflect the positive changes made
the team are disappointed that he has
not achieved their target of reducing
arrears by 1
but this year has presented a
particularly difficult operating
environment and where other housing
providers maybe experience an increase
in areas the team continue to reduce the
level of debt
it's pleasing to see that the
performance of our capital programme has
improved significantly in comparison to
last year
i'm sorry but this year has presented
sorry
the team has spent 78 of the allocated
budget compared to 37 in the previous
year ensuring we protect council's
property assets from dilapidation and
provide decent homes for our residents
the most significant success from last
year's programme are completion of all
cyclical programs for example kitchen
and bathroom replacements and window
replacements
the refurbishment refurbishment of seven
passenger lifts and the external
decorations that have been carried out
on the newington
estate excuse me
come on
the technology's beaten
right there are two planned works
projects that are delayed one of them is
the major the major structural works at
royal crescent in ramsgate and the other
is major works and improvements at
church fields in margate
um the procurement of the contract has
delayed the process of the project at
royal crescent
um the project is very complex but with
import required from multiple
stakeholders so every time we are close
to another another issue crops up
be it legal or insurance or to do with
the specifications and this stops us
progressing until we've resolved it
at church fields when attempting to
progress this project we've found that
plans developed by east kent housing are
not fit for purpose
waste and recycling were not engaged
when these designs were agreed and the
proposed location of the bin stores
would make collections impossible we
went back to the designers with the
waste and recycling department to
rethink this element
i recommend that cabinet note the report
thank you councillor bathard uh do i
have a seconder
counsellor a bob bayford um
do members agree
great
thank you very much
that now concludes